des terroristes de nationalité française
parmi les 158 prisonniers transférés
d'afghanistan vers la base américaine de
guantanamo à cuba c'est le journal le
figaro de ce matin qui fait cette
révélation
il serait sept français au total
ministère des affaires étrangères a
envoyé sur place une délégation côte
sans père cent cinquante huit détenus
d'al-qaïda se trouvent actuellement dans
la base américaine de guantanamo 158
prisonniers de 25 nationalités
différentes
selon le figaro d'aujourd'hui il y
aurait parmi eux sept français les
américains auraient averti la france il
ya une semaine et communiquer l'identité
des sept hommes officiellement le quai
d'orsay affirme n'avoir aucune certitude
et se refuse à de plus amples
commentaires
selon le figaro c'est cet aliment
français sont tous nés en france de
parents issus de l'immigration et il
résidait dans la banlieue parisienne à
lille ou à marseille avant d'être
recruté et envoyé en afghanistan
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
parle de jeunes français talibans en
décembre dernier on avait retrouvé dans
la région de tora bora le corps de
djamel loiseau
un jeune français influençable qui
s'était fait embrigadés dans les rangs
des milices extrémistes son père dos à
la caméra
à vous alors ne pas comprendre comment
son fils était un jour retrouver dans
les rangs d'al qaïda il ya quelques
semaines une de nos équipes avaient
retrouvé un certain karim un jeune
français qui avait effectué plusieurs
séjours dans les camps terroristes
karim a un peu paumé à l'époque avait
été recruté en 1995 sur un marché en
banlieue parisienne ont vu juste on a
galéré j'avais pas habilités j'avais pas
de quoi manger et au et il était là pour
m'aider vont proposer du travail mon
crime pour dormir et où je me suis senti
un petit peu redevable envers eux et en
plus eux ils demanderaient un rien de
grave au début de mon juste
venir les voir parler de faire la prière
et au karim avait à l'époque accepté de
témoigner pour éviter que d'autres
jeunes tombent dans le piège de ces
recruteurs d'al qaïda la france vient
officiellement d'envoyer une mission à
guantanamo pour vérifier toutes ces
informations sur ces sept taliban
français